order
the ice to the right 319
the nose to the left 248.
the eyes to the right 319
the nose to the left 248
so the eyes have it the eyes have it
unlocked
bill ordered to be brought in upon the
ways and means resolution who will
prepare and bring in the bill
the chairman of ways and means the prime
minister
the chancellor of the exchequer
secretary sajid javid well that's jesse
norman the financial secretary to the
treasury who actually opened this debate
much earlier today you can see on his
left that's steve barclay and uh the
prime minister was uh as you were saying
sarah in the chamber obviously wanted to
be there now let's look at the numbers
numbers are always a crucial in these
things so that was 319 to 248 now
compare that with the vote on the labor
amendment there you go majority 71 now
what is interesting about that is that
the in the first vote on the labour
amendment um the majority was 92 so the
government's majority has dropped by 21
which suggests a handful of
conservatives voting against the
government and a handful of abstentions
now i mentioned a short time ago
those who've said publicly in the debate
they're going to vote against well
abstain jake berry steve baker roger
gail
deanna david davidson
we think christopher chope
who has been very outspoken during the
course of the day and threatening to
vote against we're pretty sure he is one
of the ones voting against so the prime
minister will be delighted a majority of
71 i mean that is only nine short of the
government's majority of 80.
this sails through the way this was
being discussed at the weekend yes and
how difficult it was looking for the
prime minister what has happened since
the weekend of course is that the
government has uh pulled what uh pulled
off what many will believe is a master
stroke
combining extra money for the nhs
because of the backlogs caused by the
pandemic with the money for social care
now there are lots of doubts and lots of
questions when is the uh the backlog
money going to be switched to social
care and so on and uh sajid javid the
health secretary has been pretty vague
and non-committal about that but by
giving more money to the nhs who's going
to oppose that um we heard a lot today
uh during the course of prime minister's
questions and during the debate taunting
from the prime minister to secure
stamina the party of naiban the labour
party going to oppose more money for the
nhs well they have uh but of course the
thing that they are really opposed to is
the increases in national insurance
contributions so this i think it's fair
to say has sailed through a majority of
71 very small uh rebellion and by by
combining the two things extra money for
the nhs
which of course the government will
regard as extremely popular with the tax
rises
of course they've got it through
comfortably the prime minister said
tonight at the 1922 committee we are the
party of free enterprise the private
sector and low taxation and then he said
he couldn't think of a better use for
public money than to spend it on the
national health service so that has been
his argument to tory mps tonight and
indeed in the chamber earlier on today
so the prime minister will regard the
last two days as two days very good work
he's got his proposals through with
minimal opposition from tory back
benchers and he has comfortably won a
vote a snap vote in the house of commons
tonight